For my birthday.
We came to Yale
and the first snow of the year happened
and my tour was walking through Old Campus
and people were just building snowmen
and having a snowball fight.
I felt this feeling of home at Yale.
I knew that I had to go here.
It was my dream from that day on.
Originally, the plan had not been
to go to college right after high school.
I was very apprehensive
about even applying to Yale
because I thought I wouldn't fit in here
and I wouldn't be happy here.
It shattered my expectations
of what I thought Yale was.
I remember
watching The Why I Toured Yale video,
just like in my living room
and just thinking, this looks fun.
You've got the a cappellas, you got
the dancing groups, the cultural
affinity groups, and it just looks like
a really fun space to be in.
And I just really desired
to be a part of that.
My mom is my best friend
and so it was very hard to leave her.
She knew that
it was the best decision for me
and she wanted me to like,
reach my dreams.
And she knew
it was an incredible opportunity.
I knew that if I was going to be able
to achieve these big goals
that I had in mind,
it was going to be a tough decision
and it was going to take a big change.